[Music]
what's up everybody today we are back
with another cooking video
and we are going to be making my
all-time favorite dessert and that is
the portuguese
egg tart the portuguese egg tart is a
crunchy
flaky soft milk in your mouth dessert
comprised of a custard filling with a
puff pastry shell
now there are a couple versions of this
dish the original one being from
portugal but today we are going to be
making the chinese version of the
pastistenta
now the best thing about this pastry is
that it doubles
as the dessert and a breakfast item
there's nothing better than waking up to
the sweet smell of a portuguese egg tart
served with a cup of coffee coffee and a
portuguese egg tart is a beautiful
beautiful parrot
shout out to trade coffee this video is
brought to you by trade coffee it's a
service that lets you discover
some of the best coffees from the
nation's top roaster they match you to
your own personal selection of coffee
and they deliver that coffee
straight to your door and if you're like
me i'm pretty picky with my coffee and
i'm always trying to find the most
nuanced coffee roasts and quite frankly
being at the grocery store looking at
the rows of coffee
being on my phone researching while i'm
at the grocery store just
isn't that fun so instead this is how
trade coffee works step one you take a
quiz you tell them how you like your
coffee how you make your coffee
i like making coffee with my mocha pot
and then i like dark roasts and they'll
curate for you an
endless list of coffee for you to try
step two you can choose your frequency
of delivery
and step three you get to rate the
coffee that trade sends to you
and by rating it you'll let trade know
whether or not you like certain roasts
and they'll continue to send the ones
you absolutely love
click the link below to get 30 off your
first bag of coffee when you sign up
free shipping included if you're into
coffee or you want to learn more about
coffee
definitely check out trade coffee all
right back to the pasties de nata aka
portuguese egg tarts brief history of
portuguese egg tarts they were first
invented in a monastery by some monks in
portugal now apparently when you did
laundry back in the day you used egg
whites to help starch your linen so they
had a whole bunch of egg yolks that they
didn't know what to do with
thus the invention of pashti spinach
pretty soon portugal caught wind of the
pacifistinator
and it became portugal's most iconic
pastry portugal goes on to try and
colonize the world and one of those
places that they try colonizing
is macau china the portuguese started
introducing the pastista native to the
locals
and nowadays the portuguese egg tart is
also synonymous with the city of macau
you can't travel the macau without
trying
a portuguese egg tart known in cantonese
hot it's like eating a cream brulee with
the croissants but better
so today i am going to show you how to
make the portuguese egg tart
[Music]
first up puff pastry we'll be using one
sheet of puff pastry
i'm personally using a store-bought puff
pastry but if you want to make your own
homemade puff pastry
more power to you i'm just being lazy
because puff pastry takes a while to
make you gotta fold the butter and all
that stuff but if you're on team
store-bought
let's go next we'll be using half a cup
of heavy cream
a third of a cup of sugar one and
one-quarter cup of whole
milk two egg yolks four teaspoons of
corn starch
and one teaspoon of vanilla extract all
right the first thing we're gonna do is
work with our puff pastry we're gonna
roll it out into
a very very thin sheet and when i say
thin like
really really thin and you want it to be
about you know a
10 inch by 12 inch sheet and once you
have it flattened out into the sheets
what we're gonna do
is roll it like a roll of carpet and
what we're gonna do
from here is take some plastic wrap wrap
it up and we're gonna put it into the
freezer for 30 minutes now the thing
about puff pastry is that
it can melt there's a lot of butter
inside
puff pastry the way you make puff pastry
is to have
a dough and you put butter in you fold
it
and put butter and you fold the butter
and you fold those many layers of butter
and dough
is what creates that beautiful flake and
so
if you let this puff pastry out for too
long it starts to melt and you
lessen the amount of flakiness and the
amount of layers that you have built
into the puff pastry after 30 minutes
you're going to pull it back
out and you can feel that it's a lot
more firm from here we're going to cut
our puff pastry into 12 equal parts
about an
inch in length and what we want is to
have a spiral
pattern in the middle of the dough and
this is going to result in a really cool
looking pastry shell
take these pieces now and put it back
into the fridge one more time
and let it firm up once more
[Music]
all right now from here we're going to
take a rolling pin and we are going to
roll
each piece of puff pastry now we want to
roll it out to be
pretty thin this is going to be the
shell the custard
holder now you can use a muffin tin or
you can use the single pastry tins that
i have
and it helps a lot what i like to do is
place the tin on top so it's centered in
the middle
and then flip it over and then press and
work the dough
into the edges of the tin and you work
it around and you want to press
your thumbs into the crust and form the
crust around the rim
of the tins so once you have all the
tart tins filled with the pastry dough
we're going to take these and put it
back into the freezer and it's going to
sit in the freezer
until our custard is ready and we're
ready to pour the custard into these
shells
with the custard filling it's super easy
all we have to do is combine
all the remaining ingredients together
so first we're going to pour in
our 1 3 cup of sugar into a mixing bowl
next the half cup of heavy cream the 4
teaspoons of corn starch
and the 1 and 1 4 cup of whole milk
we're gonna take a whisk and mix our
milk mixture together and once it's
mixed well we're going to pour it into a
saucepan and we want to keep the heat
fairly low you don't want to burn
the cream or the milk or the sugar what
you want to do is keep whisking while
it's heating up
in the saucepan and once it begins to
steam you can turn off
the heat what we're really doing here is
melting the sugar and thickening
our cream and milk into more of a
custard-like texture
you'll notice that as you're whisking
some of the milk byproduct
is going to start gathering at the
bottom of the saucepan
that's okay what we're gonna do is take
a mixing bowl we're gonna place
a sieve on top of the mixing bowl and
we're gonna pour
our custard mixture through the sieve
and into the mixing bowl and you'll see
the sieve is gonna catch all that dairy
byproduct that we do not want what we
really want is our custard to be
smooth and we're going to let that
custard cool for about
30 minutes at room temp after about 30
minutes we are going to take our two
eggs and we are going to remove the egg
white from the yolk there's many ways to
remove
yolk from the egg whites my favorite way
is also the messiest way
or what i like to do is crack the egg
and just dump the entire thing into my
hands and i like to let the egg whites
drip
through the cracks in between my fingers
and once you have just the egg yolk in
your hand you can place that
gently into the custard mixture once you
have both eggs placed inside the mixing
bowl with the custard mixture
we're also gonna throw in our one
teaspoon of vanilla extract
and after that we whisk the egg the
vanilla extract
and the custard mixture together make
sure to work in the yolks very very well
and after we have it all mixed we're
gonna take another mixing bowl here
put the sieve on top of that and we're
gonna pour
our custard mixture one more time
through the sieve just to catch
any other extra by-product from the
dairy and from
our eggs that way we'll ensure the
smoothest
and cleanest custard possible now that
we have our custard done and we have our
shells
prepped what i like to do is put the
shells on a baking sheet
now the trick to our portuguese egg
tarts assembly
is having the egg tart shells super
super cold
and our custard needs to be not hot
because the last thing we would want is
to pour our hot custard in
and it starts to melt our puff pastry
and when that happens the custard and
the pastry
would actually start blending together
you want the clear distinction
between custard and pastry so
temperature is very important from here
we're going to take a spoon
and what you want to do is spoon just
enough custard into the shells
where it covers about three quarters of
the way full now once that's done we're
going to take our entire batch of egg
custards
and we're going to put it into the oven
that's been preheated to 450 degrees now
you might be thinking 450 degrees
that's freaking hot it is freaking hot
so the higher the temperature
the crunchier the puff pastry will be
and
it allows us to scorch the top of our
egg tarts so we get that iconic
caramelized look we're going to let that
bake for 20 minutes
and at the 20 minute mark we're going to
turn off the oven and let it bake for
another 10 minutes in the residual heat
inside the oven so our portuguese egg
tarts are going to spend
a grand total of 30 minutes inside the
oven and after the 30 minutes we're
gonna pull out the egg custards
and let it rest for another 15 minutes
at this point your kitchen is going to
smell
wonderful that beautiful buttery scent
from the puff pastry
the caramelization of the sugar you can
smell
and if you were me i'd be making a
coffee right about now so i can have
a fresh egg custard and a coffee to pair
with now these
make for great desserts but they're also
great for breakfast
what i like to do is reheat my egg tarts
in the morning you can set your toaster
oven to 350 degrees and let it sit in
there for about eight to nine minutes
and then you have a fresh and crunchy
egg tart ready to go
on any given day hope you guys enjoyed
this video make sure to head down to the
comments below
and let me know what you think about
this recipe if you guys do end up making
this
make sure to tag me on my instagram i'd
love to see your creations like always
let me know what you want me to make
next once again shout out to trade
coffee they're giving anyone who clicks
on the link below
30 off their first bag of coffee and
until next time
[Music]
hmm
you